привіт я 2 луганську та ми сьогодні
поговоримо про гроші куди й навіщо
витрачаються наші бюджетні гроші
27 кримінальних справ розслідуються у
відношенні
Петра Порошенка 5 президента України
словами генерального прокурора України
ірини
венедиктова та збитки, які нібито завдав
Петро Порошенко державі складає
півтора мільйона гривень за наявною у
мене інформації я реально прокуратура
задіяв у цих 27 кримінальних справах
аж цілих 41 прокурора які обходяться
нам лише у вигляді однієї заробітної плати
без премій на місяць в 1 мільйон 962 000
150 одну гривню щороку становить 23
мільйона п'ятсот сорок п'ять тисяч
вісімсот три гривні, але це ще не все
державне бюро розслідувань
задіяла 54 слідчих які
обходяться нам у місяць у вигляді заробітної плати
плати у 2 мільйони 980 3300 одну гривню
що на рік становить 35 мільйонів
сімсот дев'яносто дев'ять тисяч шістсот
8 хв
генеральна прокуратура 23 мільйони
п'ятсот сорок п'ять тисяч на рік
слідчих державне бюро
розслідувань 35 мільйонів у 790 тисяч у
рік на 54 слідчого і того на рік ось
ця вся історія на 27 кримінальних справ нам
з вами платником податків наших із вами
грошей
обходиться в 59 мільйонів
340 5411
наших кровних із вами
рівне увагу питання зелений маркер
взяв спеціально увагу питання 59
мільйонів і півтора мільйона о котрій
ж раз нам дорожче обходиться зелений
зі своїми переслідувачами взяли
прокуратурою dbr та можливі збитки
який наніс порошенка порахуйте
напишіть у коментарях що ви думаєте
з цього приводу